voici la nouvelle brigade de bénévoles
qui règne désormais sur villeneuve
quelques-uns des douze citoyens les plus
attentifs de la commune leur mission
c'est d'alerté très concrètement vous
balader dans la rue vous voyez à une
camionnette qu'il ya des agissements
bizarres qui ralentit il devant les
maisons qu'ils surveillent
voilà tout ce qui peut paraître bizarre
et vous leur remontée à la gendarmerie
et bien entendu où ni uniforme ni képi
hors de question pour eux de remplacer
les gendarmes
on est le relais au niveau de la
gendarmerie mais en aucun accord
n'intervient s'il ya un problème entre
deux voisins importe on prévient tout de
suite la gendarmerie mais on va surtout
pas s'interposer entre les deux mais
simplement avertir les forces de l'ordre
le dispositif participation citoyenne
c'est devenir l'oeil de la commune
prévenir les méfaits ransom prendre soin
de ses voisins et pas l'un vers ce ne
sont pas là pour faire de la
surveillance du voisinage ils sont pas
là pour épier le voisin savoir si le
voisin il parle non c'est pas le but le
but c'est pas du tout ça le but de se
créer un
un réseau d'observateurs et de personnes
susceptibles de nous amener des
informations pour pouvoir lutter contre
le col et cambriolages par exemple
villeneuve sur cher seulement 400
habitants et pourtant ici aussi la
sécurité est primordiale
même si c'est un petit village
tranquille on a toujours peur quand on
voit ce qui se passe aux alentours
avant ça se passait dans les grandes
villes et maintenant quand on regarde la
presse
on s'aperçoit que nos petites communes
sont aussi touchés alors la
participation citoyenne séduit deux
communes alentours devraient intégrer le
dispositif d'ici la fin de l'année